va faire l'interview fin de phrase
[Musique]
donc ça commence avec vos fred je vous
dis le début de la phrase nous dit la
fin si je n'avais pas rencontré omar et
bien je serai décédé omar fred est
tellement drôle que que je ris tout le
temps ouais ça c'est vrai il rit en fait
on peut le regarder et d'année très fait
je ne sais pas si je dois le dire ou non
mais omar pierre qui roule n'amasse pas
mousse omar ce que j'aime chez le pen
c'est sais rien il y avait son tibia
bref la seule chose qui me ferait aimer
les hommes c'est que vous marrer la peau
-12 que les autres hommes a
effectivement un noir et un blanc
ensemble ça c'est des ménages tous les
deux on a un truc en commun c'est qu'on
déteste gros con de de michel vosgien
non directeur de la socotec
ouais c'est vrai
tous mais on n'est pas là pour donner
son nom en revanche on est fan de pascal
obispo série laisse nous te dire une
fois pour toutes que faisons l'amour
nous dire adieu ce que je regarde
l'émission franchement en maintenant on
peut dire que kannad ckoi canal chérie
c'est incroyable depuis la dernière fois
est ce que tu as beau aussi si on devait
se souvenir d'une vanne à nous ça serait
ce serait un homme persuadé que sa femme
le trompe rentrer chez lui il dit à sa
femme chérie je sais tout avons su en
quelle année il est mort napoléon je
peux la refaire avec une valse ça serait
ces deux mecs qui sont dans un mariage
et s'approche du buffet et lundi à
l'autre jean pierre schoeller faire du
vin oui merci mes mots c'est yves cela
est passé on regardera la gare à celles
la république dans les belles années du
canal dans les bureaux y avait beaucoup
de pierre lescure et d'alain de greef
vous appeler ça comme ça
oui chérie tu es vraiment un un homme
dommage il ne lui a pas dit what suivent
enfin d'accord d'accord ce qui est bien
chez ben laden c'est qu'il nous a fait
préférer train bien sûr avec ben laden
si possible si jamais ça s'arrête demain
ça sera à cause de toi le jour le plus
heureux de ma vie
ça fait dix ans qu'ils durent le vrai
problème du foulard à l'école c'est
surtout pour la piscine sinon c'est bien
longtemps
depuis que je suis connue c'est plus
facile pour les autographes
les gens me demandent à voir il en avait
rien à [ __ ] je réponds les distribuer
dans la rue kruyt star flyer pour le
soir et rabat c'est cool il ne faut pas
vendre la peau de l'ours
surtout si l'on sait des dents encore le
nouveau rôle de nadi al pacino qui me la
piquer dans scarface un nom sera s'était
taillé sur mesure pour moi non et
finalement nous dans la vie ce que je
sais faire le mieux c'est c'est pas moi
qu'il faut demander ça à mon ex
savage peut me raconter de temps en
temps qu'est ce qu'il ya tu vas me le
cash et met à raconter je me racontes là
parce que je préfère c'est charles de
gaulle 6ème aéroport
ça c'est sûr
quand je regarde la tv quand je regarde
la télé moi aussi maintenant j'ai peur
des arabes à l'âge que je peux dire est
ce que je préfère chez dieudonné
sa rapidité d'esprit non mais c'est vrai
parce que là c'est tellement c'est petit
flip maintenant tu parles est devenu
c'est extraordinaire alors que c'est
disproportionné ce qui lui arrive je
trouve vraiment même s'il n'était pas
très drôle le jour de france 2 c'est
marc-olivier fogiel de rendez hommage
ouais il me rendait hommage donc j'ai
dans une situation délicate mais c'est
vrai que j'ai été jouée à liège la n'y a
pas très longtemps et il abat aussi il a
été interdit donc je trouve vraiment que
ça prend des proportions incroyables je
peux vous le dire et je le signe
dieudonné n'est pas antisémite qui
s'excuse fallu s'excuser et on leur
pardonnera s'il s'excuse franchement il
faut il faut ça s'est excusé serravalle
ce qu'ont à dire les anges et d'egis
excuses ça voudrait dire qu'il est qu'il
est qu'il ait antisémites en anglais
veut dire que malheureusement peut-être
que il a fait une gaffe voilà il
haïssait mais c'est parce qu'il sait pas
ce qui se passe qui dit laver nos
mélodies l'île du ballet parce que je
lui au téléphone il m'a dit j'ai été
maladroit ce n'est pas très sympa non
oui alors moi c'est oui alors dans ce
cas la visite aurait dû être le moment
il m'appelait
donc je ne vais me baudelot afin d'
accord allait le plus dur quand on monte
un one man show
cette ferrari sont tous les matins quand
je me réveille tous les matins quand je
me réveille je me lève et je te bouscule
et je travaille par un peu comme
d'habitude avant de monter sur scène je
suis souvent en coulisses on peut rire
de tout sauf on peut rire de tout sauf
si c'est pas marrant si un jour j'ai un
fils je l'appellerai bref si un jour
j'ai un fils ou une fille je
l'appellerai
une fois par an j'ai bien ce que je
préfère chez moi c'est ce que je préfère
chez moi c'est mon canapé la dernière
fois que j'ai pris de la coke à la fac
j'ai pris de la coke
je m'en souviens pas très bien parce que
je devais être sous acide je ne sais pas
si je dois le dire ou non je sais pas si
je dois te dire ou non alors je crois
que je vais pas le dire
ce que j'aime chez les antisémites a
sérieusement
ouais y'a un truc que j'aime bien avec
les antisémites moi j'aime bien parler
avec les antisémites
vraiment j'adore ça parce que quand je
parle avec des juifs j'entends que des
problèmes c'est les problèmes qu'on a en
france et les problèmes avec les
mariages mixtes les problèmes avec les
gars israélo-arabe les problèmes
d'accord je parle avec des antisémites
j'entends que des bonnes nouvelles c'est
les juifs qui ont tout l'argent c'est le
judo
alors on peut plus rien dire on va faire
le test ultime pour savoir si on peut
vraiment plus rien dire on va faire une
interview fin de phrase
[Musique]
d'accord je dis pas qu'il ya des [ __ ]
des drogués à la télé jeudi que magic ya
deux ans il ya des gens il ya des gens
différents
pascal sevran les 134 la santé par
exemple
mais aujourd'hui encore dit alors ce qui
est bien quand et pdc
bah c'est que t'as pas besoin de divorce
et encore plus quand ça va peut-être
venir
je rêve d'une france nettoyer deux des
journalistes qui me posent des questions
de compte vraiment c'est celle et deux
invités didier nicolas sarkozy a raison
il faut absolument faire parler de soi
il ne faut pas jeter la pierre au
pédophile car tu pourrais blessé
l'enfant qui porte dans les bras
tu vois à tirer un handicap et c'est
toujours avec un peu de chance parce qu
il ya plein de place pour les handicapés
de stationnement on interdit la voiture
en ville
je suis pour la parité hommes femmes
bien sûr sauf si sauf si laurent baffie
est remplacé par christine boutin
la phrase qu'il ne faut surtout pas dire
en ce moment c'est on peut pas plaire à
tout le monde
j'aime bien voir des flics dans la rue
parce que son pendant le bistrot est le
vrai problème avec les juifs aujourd'hui
c'est pas problème j'ai beaucoup ont dit
que les arabes sont voleurs c'est faux
hier d'apprendre tous les musulmans ne
sont pas des terroristes mais lent mais
il est petit musulmane c'est des petites
bombes mois les qualifiés on pourra
jamais enlever un islamiste c'est dans
maires des bouches
non
ça va bien
ce qui m'énerve chez les catholiques
c'est ça c'est qu'ils élisent des papes
un peu trop un peu trop black et surtout
trop jeune les inconnues sont mais qu'on
met tout le monde en parle voilà
exactement alors bernard tapie comme
vous êtes le roi de la tchatche vous
allez finir mes phrases je vous donne le
début de la fin en ce moment je sais pas
ce que j'aimais ça se présente pas mal
c'est bien un truc que je sais pas faire
c'est faire semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire bravo
ce qui manque à chirac par rapport à
mitterrand c'est jacques séguéla le seul
truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec
l'argent c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plus tôt pourquoi
en général je plus aux femmes qui ont le
goût du risque
c'est vrai au moins franchement
maintenant je peux te dire l'émission
que je faisais sur tf1 je regrette de
l'avoir arrêté à y aller comme ça une
bonne tête mais montrant d'orge tionale
âge pour pour t'apprendre que tu fais
pas la différence entre l'acier alors tu
avais des prêts des barrois en quoi ont
lâché à la santé le court
non mais il a été sympa avec moi parce
qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça et je vais
garder un on est on faisait les missions
sur canal juste juste avant que j'y
aille vie j'ai un truc pour toi tu le
regardes quand tu seras parties intimes
d'une quinte autre approche quand je
sors je regarde ce que c'était car du
monopoly vous êtes libéré de prison
assez bien
et cathy seine-saint-denis sterrebeek
son micro en direct à la télévision
thierry est incroyable depuis la
dernière fois ce que tu as tu sens plus
heureux mais il n'y a même pas de
comparaison c'est le soir qui fait ça ça
égaye tout ce sont eux doit vraiment
porte bien le deuil je sens que ça y est
voilà le jour mais 60 ans je me suis dit
tout marche et tout marche
ah ouais t'as besoin de viagra du cialis
et c'est là dedans le bon soir et
franchement si tu avais été au ballon à
ma place je suis sûr que dans les boîtes
et alors été plus normal ça aurait fait
plus normal merde
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener ses chansons de brassens qui dit
les gens n'aiment pas que l'on suive pas
le même chemin que ouais bah c'est un
peu ce contre cela que c'était dur et
mauvaise réputation c'est ce qu'ils
veulent pas qu'on soit différent quoi
c'est qu'ils sont nombreux aujourd'hui
ce qui me rend le plus fier c'est mes
enfants les quatre
c'est marrant malgré tout ce que j'ai
vécu je continue à croire que qu'il faut
toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas alors ça je me le dis jamais jamais
jamais pas une fois je me suis dit ah si
j'avais su jamais c'est ce que j'aime
dans la vie j'ai pas de rétroviseur mais
par contre je garde c'est ce qui fait
que je garde jamais demeuré souvenirs
des gens qui m'ont fait chier je promets
à celui qui me traitent encore dans à 10
m 1 pas c'est sûr sont des souvenirs
d'un truc chez moi j'aimerais que ce
soit j'ai fait une des écoles pour les
jeunes qui étaient sans boulot ouais et
on à la sortie près de 10000 sans rien
demander à personne et il y en a près de
10000 dans la nature
ouais que rue belle carrière grâce à mme
parmi tous les salopards qui m'ont trahi
je n'oublierai jamais bien que mes potes
n'étaient pas dans le lot faire une
interview fin de phrase
alors christophe je vous donnais les
débuts de phrases si vous avez aimé
terminer par exemple rires c'est un bon
moyen de 2
poser les bonnes questions je dois tout
à à la méthode ogino la religion c c'est
une vaste rumeurs persistantes depuis
que je suis connue c'est plus facile
c'est plus facile de c'est plus facile
de téléphoner au volant
ouais j'ai grandi entouré de m'entourer
de parfum et d'amour
la nature bien gâtés au niveau de niveau
2 au niveau de l'assurance alors tu veux
dire
pour 2006 j'ai décidé d'arrêter de
utiliser d'arrêter d'arrêter si l'alcool
me gêne dans le travail à temps laisse
la finir cette vanne à la tâche
qu'elle en profite bien parce qu'elles
pensent qu'on est en 2005 encore un
c'était cabral a fini ses vastes gammes
pas celle d'un amour a toujours fait
comme ça
lacina lequel me gêne dans le travail
j'arrête immédiatement
ouais bon
alors non non moi ça fait vers la mecque
j'ai trois mois pour me détendre je fais
beaucoup de de sport je lis l'équipe
la france c'est le pays n'a pas bien
marché la précédente d'aller à la
bataille de barrir sur la proche
la france est un pays de 2 2 de voltaire
rousseau hugo et malheureusement sarkozy
là tu vas te faire un copain c'est
qu'arnaud et j'ai pas l'ump a renommé
vous quand même vous avez pour sarkozy
il se trouve qu'il s'attaque à de vrais
problèmes et propose de vraies solutions
et pas simplement de mettre les choses
sous le tapis en attendant que ça passe
bon il ya le village mérite là et on
peut pas lui ôter je pense pile-poil
inverse
il aime beaucoup mais on peut pas dire à
tort il a raison pas dire qu'ils mettent
les problèmes sous le tapis c'est vrai
bonne question il a les mauvaises
réponses pas exactement la bilan qui est
du vent du début à la fin la fin ce mec
est un courant d'air et je pense qu'en
plus il est il est parfaitement
dangereux alors on continue
vous finissez mes phrases 1 je suis fan
de 2
non je suis fan de dodo père sur une
pontoise n'a vous reporter lui aussi
j'adore ça nous fait encore
sarkozy elle n'a pas ça
tu vas prendre l'ascenseur je pourrais
me reconvertir dans dans peut-être dans
la politique ah si j'étais dieu je
ferais je suis enfant dieu si j'ai je
ferais je ferai quelque chose pour que
que mon fils ne meurt pas dans ses
souffrances atroces enfin je rend moins
vacciner contre le tétanos ou la seule
fois où je me suis fait [ __ ] c'est
ben c'est sans doute la première fois où
j'ai tourné le dos à mon banquier
alors attention la force de laurent
ruquier c'est à ces de m'avoir engagé
non je pense le rock et c'est vraiment
d'être sympa avec je crois tout le tout
le monde et des décès dont l'internet
je le dis parce qu'il est vraiment
il de se faire tout ce faire contredire
violemment
donc
2 le côté écouter aussi voilà ce qui est
impressionnant chez stv c'est ça c'est
sa mère c'est sa mère non je le dis
sérieusement à sa mère que j'ai
rencontrés qui est une femme adorable
ah ouais mais lui aussi lui aussi
d'ailleurs rien
la plus grande erreur de ma vie c'est la
grand-mère de civils
j'aimerais bien avoir une plus grosse ou
plus grosse grosse mais tiendrait pas
dans l'ascenseur thierry tu m'excite
quand tu alors tu m'excite tu sais quoi
quand c'est quand tu poses des questions
que cela puisse écoute les t'écoute les
réponses et souvent tu fais c'est
excitant
bah ouais c
alors bouder rires c'est un bon moyen de
communication oui je dois tout à dieu
j'ai grandi entouré de entouré des
cafards ça continue non la chirurgie un
carré d'as mais c'est la première fois
qu'un tueur est pourtant de belles
filles arrêtent son ballon mais jean de
cafard quand leur métier du bégo aisés
comme ça tu peux mon métier
[Applaudissements]
la nature m'a bien gâtés au niveau 2 de
mon nez oui j'ai un bonnet c'est vrai
pour 2006 j'ai décidé de l'arrêter
j'ai décidé d'arrêter d'être où est
réunie à wii sports d'esprit bon sens
mouss diouf je serai au stade mosquées
poussent les dernières magasin c'est
vrai mais dans la coulisse mais en
restant mais je te jure sylla faut qu'il
vient de 4e
la nouvelle
[Musique]
mettez-vous à bellevue pour moi merci
bonsoir
ça va de changer de rien tu restes un
pour le brent et smooth non écoute alors
il reste à la france c'est le pays
c'est le pire les doigts de leur ont dit
non la france est le pays c'est le pays
de moi je suis fan de tout fan de
dorothée
ah oui j'ai pas honte de le dire la
seule fois où je me suis fait [ __ ]
sait si dans une sandwicherie
ouais j'ai payé un sandwich avait rien
dedans
[Applaudissements]
la force de le pen c'est la cannelle il
est trop fort avec un oeil c'est chaud
j'ai jamais dit ça à personne mais mes
laurent baffie qui est un diable pendjab
chettab
c'est vrai j'ai été voir tous ces trucs
même dit qu'ils n'ont pas ce qu'elle est
que les abonnés à des mois dit il faut
pas y aller seul mais bien fait d'avoir
respecté la consigne sont nombreux oui
car au sein du slogan que jour
j'aimerais bien avoir une plus grosse
montre parce qu'il n'est pas tjrs à
l'est du mexique quand tu as tu dis moi
dis et auxerre magnette
[Musique]